do you who understands the car
accident okay were you just talking to
them they're telling me that I go you
messing up this reading over here I'm
trying to do this I'm so sorry so what I
love about that sorry what validating
for you that they heard you do you
understand that what what plans changed
that day cuz what happened is they put
me in the car and they switched my seat
so that's my symbol for that plans
change that they they switch cars or
they switch
drivers what
um well we were supposed to go out
together I stayed home I acted like I
was asleep and she went with my best
friend it was both of them in the car
and usually when we went out together I
always took a ride with the best friend
but since I wasn't there my sister did
cuz she didn't like going in the car
with her and they they died they both Di
and you have been carrying this burden
oh my God for years for
decades validating for you that they do
not want you to carry this burden of
feeling that if you were there or
somehow you could have been responsible
do you understand that or if you went
this never would have
happened so I miss her and I love her so
much you just did ma'am she also just
told me that you connect with the song
on the radio that reminds you of her
it's not a current top 40 hit right not
playing it on purpose no know that that
is her soul her energy that is with you
at the exact moment so know
that she wants to thank you for that and
know that everything that you see is
truly her and that she hasn't left you
oh thank you so much don't thank me
thank her she's the one that she's the
one that did it I love my she's
the best oh my do we understand the
hitting of the head that was her okay
and do you think that she suffered I
could I think she did it was a tragic
car accident cuz she hit me in the back
of the head and then what she did is she
then had this blow to the chest and she
made me feel like I I I didn't I
immediately left the physical body okay
so I was told that before Oh my God yes
she says I need you to believe that I
did not suffer to my death or if anyone
got to me sooner that I would still be
here thank God no that my soul
immediately left oh thank you God I'm
very sorry for the loss thank you so
much sister thank you so much I wish you
all the best I appreciate you God you do
this all the time this is so intense I
could keep
[Applause]
[Music]
going thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home